we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here is a caller who is
skeptical that Gavin Newsom really has
what it takes to be president take a
listen to this
hey David so I wanted to ask you a
question about Gavin Newsom so me and a
friend were talking about the Avenue
some potentially running for president
in 2024 and he's a republican he was
laughing a little bit he was like the
state of California doesn't even like
Newsom he almost got um the recall and
now all of a sudden you guys are pushing
him possibly for president he's going to
get crushed blah blah blah I mean what
do you think about his analysis as Gavin
Newsom and I know you've talked about
the whole recall thing but um yeah the
analysis is is very much wrong so Gavin
Newsom isn't well liked in California
okay well let's look at the numbers in
2018 Gavin Newsom won
62-38 in California okay that's a pretty
major win and in 2020 uh let's see what
what did Biden even win with in 2020
Biden got basically the same yeah so
almost identical numbers California
Biden and Newsome both one with very
similar numbers low 60s the recall
election even in the recall which is
sort of the odds are stacked against you
in a recall because the recall is
brought by period people that don't like
you so by by definition recalls often
have low turnout skewed to the group
that wants the official removed
he also got 62 percent of the vote in
the recall
so I think Gavin newsom's numbers are
absolutely fine I don't see an issue at
all does that mean that he would win an
election a national election for the
presidency of course not what's what's
the political climate at the time
who's the Republican Challenger is it
Newsome versus DeSantis is it Newsom
versus Trump is it Newsome versus Nikki
Haley there's no way to say Newsome
would win
but the idea that the California numbers
prove Newsome's not popular Now give me
a break news someone with really good
numbers in 2018 and he survived the
recall with the same exact numbers I
mean even that I believe that in a
gubernatorial race and we will see in
November Newsom may win with even bigger
numbers if the recall went so poorly for
those who wanted to remove him it's hard
to imagine that he's gonna not do well
in November but we will see I don't see
it as a problem whatsoever on the bonus
show today congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez and other lawmakers were
arrested for protesting of the Supreme
Court there are people fixating on AOC
pretending to be handcuffed and then
raising a fist I'm going to talk about
that and tell you about whether that's
even really the main part of the story
hint it's not secondly the Doctor Who
provided the abortion to the 10 year old
girl who had to go from Ohio to Indiana
is now suing the Attorney General of
Indiana for defamation we will talk
about what's going on there and third
inflation is real and it's a problem for
many people and we've been talking about
it but economists are now getting wise
to the fact that inflation is providing
cover for price fixing not just price
gouging price gouging is one thing price
fixing this is price collusion is
another way to put it and we're going to
talk about that on the bonus show as
well three things for you to do number
one sign up as a member at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code Obama Obama to get a discount you
will get instant access to the bonus
show as well as the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
number two make sure you're subscribed
to our second YouTube channel Pac-Man
Live because on Tuesday we'll be doing
our next viewer Town Hall everyone is
welcome to call in but you will only be
able to watch the town hall on the
Pac-Man Live YouTube channel and number
three
don't send me any hate messages those
are the instructions thank you see
everybody either on the bonus show or
tomorrow on our next episode